la fin des vacances a sonné et ma entre
en ce2 à l'école élémentaire frédéric
mistral de bois d'arcy comme chaque
année elle est entourée de sa famille
j'ai pu être là à chaque rentrée ça me
fait toujours plaisir quand ça viendra
peut-être qu'elle voudra plus trop de
moi aux abords de l'école mais on n est
pas là donc jamais bon ben voila comme
emma ce sont deux cent trente trois
élèves qui font leur rentrée dans
l'établissement cette année un retour
qui peut entrer c'est certain
a un peu stressé comme d'habitude mais
ça va
ça devrait passer j'ai juste peur des
traces dans ce que c'est la plus sévère
en chine en formant et en réjouir
d'autres avec ma maîtresse je vais me
sentir
[Musique]
bien tous les matins lui dire bonjour
avec mes amis travaillent ensemble je
l'attendais beaucoup pas parce que bah
je renvoie toutes mes amis et aussi
j'espère que la maîtresse sera gentil
enfin j'ai un soutien aussi tout va bien
on est démasqué il fait beau non non
motivée j'espère que les élèves le
seront aussi on a vraiment beaucoup de
chance à bois d'arcy parce qu'on a
toutes les écoles qui sont complètes
avec évidemment tous les enseignants
présents les animateurs les atsem tous
les agents de la ville aussi donc c'est
une très très belle rentrée une dernière
photo pour immortaliser le moment et il
est temps de faire ses premiers pas en
classe présentation règlement de l'école
et même calcul mental les premières
impressions fusent déjà à la sortie de
ma classe et elle est formidable j la
meilleure classe avec les avec tel est
le
et mais madame barreaux elle n'est pas
si sévère que ça en fait ah c'était
vraiment bien pour une première fois
avec madame barreau j'ai trouvé que
c'était plutôt cool et je suis sûr bac
elle sera aussi gentil que jarres
d'huile pendant toute l'année c'est une
nouvelle année qui débute pour près de
trois cent mille élèves yvelinois les
vacances de la toussaint comment seront
quant à elle le 22 octobre prochain